demain à luxembourg c'est le paysage
audiovisuel européen que les 12 vont
dessiner et pour longtemps
il y a tout lieu d'être inquiet en effet
le mois dernier à bruxelles le compromis
qui a été signé à ignorer la volonté
française d'imposer aux futures chaînes
européennes
un minimum de 60% de production locale
cet après midi à l'assemblée nationale
de tous les groupes politiques sans
exception
les questions ont fusé vers catherine
tasca le ministre de la communication a
réaffirmé qu'elle continuera de se
battre demain à luxembourg pas de quoi
rassurer tout de même les professionnels
de la télévision
c'est le dossier de michel vial la
directive européenne sur la télévision
sans frontières adoptée il ya un mois à
bruxelles constitue à munich de
l'audiovisuel c'est l'avis des
professionnels français qui se sont
mobilisés en force contre elle depuis
une semaine
si cette directive est entériné demain à
luxembourg les futures chaînes
européennes ne seront plus tenus de
réserver au moins 60 % de leur temps
d'antenne à des oeuvres en provenance de
la communauté
d'où le cri d'alarmé des professionnels
décidés à se battre pour empêcher
l'invasion de produits américains et
japonais
robin signer cet accord il faut demander
un délai de réflexion aux autres pays
européens c'est très simple et ils ne
peuvent pas nous refuser quand ils
seront la détermination unanime de la
profession française qui ne peuvent pas
nous le refuser et d'ailleurs je répète
c'était prévu au mois de juin
pendant cette période de réflexion
essayons de trouver un autre accord
possible
edith cresson et catherine tasca ont
tour à tour affirmé que la france avait
toujours défendu une préférence
européenne en termes de quotas mais
qu'elle s'était trouvée singulièrement
isoler le 13 mars d'où ce compromis qui
a évité une réglementation beaucoup plus
libérale est infiniment plus dangereuse
pour l'europe du visuel mais les
professionnels français estime que
l'abandon des quotas entraînera la mort
du cinéma européen lequel dépend
étroitement de la télévision et dans
leur lettre au président de la
république il demande que demain à
luxembourg la france revienne à ses
positions initiales j'ai pas trouvé ce
jeu pas de garder dans un tiroir
quelques vieilles choses comme on joue
comme on garde les livres de son grand
père non il s'agit de l'avenir il s'agit
de mains des artisans du culturel je
crois qu'on pourrait ajourner qu'on
pourrait réfléchir et que se mette en
marche dans tous les états de la
communauté des mouvements comme le nôtre
ou d art
des réalisateurs en particulier de
cinéma et télévision des auteurs du
cinéma et de télévision dans des
associations internationales qui
existent vont tirer les sonnettes
d'alarmé ça m'étonnerait vraiment que le
gouvernement français se lance dans un
conflit ouvert avec l'unanimité de
l'audio de l'audiovisuel français
à deux mois des élections européennes
mais si vous n'êtes pas entendu jusqu'où
pouvez-vous aller nous pouvons aller
jusqu à toute une série de
manifestations que jusqu'à maintenant
nous n'avons pas osé imaginer
sur l'ensemble de télévision de la
communauté à l'heure actuelle seuls 30%
des émissions diffusées sont d'origine
européenne tandis que les productions
américaines japonaises ou brésilienne
coûte dix fois moins chère que celle de
n'importe quel pays européen
ces deux chiffres suffisent à nourrir
l'inquiétude et la détermination des
professionnels français dont quelques
représentants ont annoncé leur désir de
faire demain le voyage de luxembourg